[संगीत]
खुदा
सो हेलो गैस मैं हूं
की यार मेरी आवाज सही ए रही है की नहीं
सबको क्योंकि आजकल बहुत लोगों को सुबह
मेरी आवाज की वजह
हो रहा है क्या
समझ में ए जाएगी
चलो कंफर्मेशन
सिक्योरिटी
तो आगे बढ़ते हैं
तो आज अपन चालू करेंगे
तो क्या है वो स्ट्रिंग है की अपना
नंबर है की क्या है डेट है टाइम मतलब क्या
है वो चीज ठीक है ना तो क्या होता है ना
जब कोई अपन कुछ डाटा है इनपुट करवा रहे
होते हैं किसी भी यूजर से या फिर
ऑटोमेटिक सिस्टम
है ये ठीक तो ऐसा चीज रहती है तो उसे
रिकॉर्डिंग डाटा स्टोर होता है
ना इस कलम है ना या आप नंबर ही दाल सकते
हो या इस कलम में यही दाल सकते हो ये इस
कलम में इतना ही डिजिटल का चीज है आप दाल
सकते हैं ठीक है ना तो वैसे चीज राहत है
तो मोस्टली तीन टाइप होते हैं अपने स्केल
के अंदर एक स्ट्रिंग होता है एक नंबर होता
है डेट और टाइम होता है ठीक है बाइनरी भी
राहत है ठीक है ना फाइल स्टोर वगैरा करने
के लिए बट अभी हम इतना डीपी में नहीं
देंगे
तो उसके बाद में आगे अपन और करेंगे ठीक है
तो बढ़ते हैं
अपना सिस्टम
कर शक्ति है अपने प्लेटफॉर्म
अपन अब इसको सिक्के से बताएंगे यह मुझे
बताना था आप लोगों की यह चीज यह एक ही चीज
है जो डफर करती है प्लेटफॉर्म वाइस बाकी
है स्क्वायर के अंदर कुछ भी चीज नहीं है
बट बहुत सी चीज ऐसी भी जो आम है ठीक है ना
तो वो चीज करेंगे इसके अंदर ठीक है तो
देखो इसके जो रेट है ना डाटा टाइप्स अपने
स्टोरी
करेगा वह डाटा कितना शुरू करेगा तो है ना
सबकी लिमिट होती है तो वैसे ही अपना एक
केयर है
अपना साइन करते हैं तो उसके आगे अपुन को
साइज देना पड़ता है उसका यार इसका साइज
क्या होना चाहिए कितना स्टोर नहीं करोगे
ताकि मेमोरी एलोकेशन में है ना सही राहत
है
इसके अंदर आपने देखा होगा जिनके बहुत
बड़े-बड़े नाम होते हैं वो जब जा के
लेटेस्ट शो करने जाते हैं उनका शॉर्ट नाम
से ए जाते हैं वहां कुछ कुछ टाइम मतलब कुछ
कैरक्टर्स के बाद में उनका नाम कार्ड देते
हैं ठीक है ना अगर सही है तो
वैसा राहत है
है ना तो क्या रेट है जो 2022 तक स्टोर कर
पता है ना एक करैक्टर कम से कम एक से दो
बीते लेट है ठीक है ना तो अब 2000 बिट्स
के 2018 ठीक है ना ज्यादा ऊपर नीचे नहीं
रहेगा एक-दो ही व्हाइट लेट है कोई एक
करैक्टर ठीक है ना एवरेज बता रहा हूं मैं
ऐसा ठीक है फिर एक और केयर राहत है ठीक है
ना जो ये यूनिकोड वगैरा लेने कम आता है
नेशनल कैरक्टर्स वगैरा लेट है ठीक है ना आ
यूनिकोड अपने थोड़ा अलग राहत है जब मैं
कीबोर्ड में राहत है उसके अलावा भी बहुत
सी और भी रहते हैं कैरक्टर्स तो वो
यूनिकोड के अंदर अपने आते हैं
की स्टोर करता है ठीक है फिर आता है ये
वैरायटी
तू जो है ना ये स्ट्रिंग स्टोर करता है
तो ये देखो
चक्कर में इनको उसे करते हैं अलग-अलग
लेकिन बाकी इनके स्पेशल फीचर्स भी होते
हैं ठीक है
यार क्या करता है क्या करता है ठीक है ना
तो वह चीज आप एक बार देखना शुरू करके
बताना यह आपको हो सके तो मैं टैक्स पर ही
दे दूंगा ये एक दीप में आप मुझे बताओ
ना ये आपको दिखता है हर जगह मिलेंगे
की हां भाई हम हमारे साथ चलेंगे तो अपन
यहां पर हो रहा है कल कर रहे हैं तो अभी
अपन विकेट 2 का मेली इस्तेमाल करेंगे ठीक
है
तो ये ये कर है तो इतने कर में सीमित नहीं
है ये और वेयर के भी होता है इसके अंदर
ठीक है ना तो वो भी और चीज भी है बट ये जो
है ये मुख्य हैं जो अधिकतर हर जगह पे
इस्तेमाल होते हैं ठीक है ना
रुद्रा भाई आपको
और अच्छे से एक्सप्लेन करने का चाहिए कौन
सा वाला पार्ट अच्छे से स्पेंड करने का है
इसके अंदर
रुद्रा रुद्रा
डिस्क्रिप्शन
यह अभी इतना लोड मत तो इस चीज को क्या
होता है क्या होता है जहां पर इस चीजों को
प्रैक्टिकल करके लेकर जाएंगे ना तो ये चीज
और क्लियर होगी ठीक है ना बट फिर भी अगर
आप कहते हो की सस्पेंड करो तो कोई बात
नहीं एक्सप्लेन कर देता हूं धीरे टाइप कुछ
नहीं होता एक डाटा कार्ड टाइप कहते हैं
उसको ठीक है ना अपन जब भी स्पेल के अंदर
अपन टेबल्स वगैरा करते हैं शायद आप मेरे
ख्याल से फर्स्ट लेक्चर में नहीं आए थे
रुद्रा रुद्रा
टेबल फॉर्म करके बताया था
ठीक है तो
हर हर कलम के अंदर अपन एक डाटा भारते हैं
तो उसे डाटा भरने के अंदर डिफाइन करना
पड़ता है वहां पर की यह
डाटा का टाइप क्या होगा
क्या यह नंबर होगा क्या यह डेट होगा या
टाइम होगा की फाइल होगी की क्या होगा
यह अपना डाटा का टाइप होता है
ठीक है
क्या
आने का इसके अंदर है अपने भी बाद में सब
कुछ फिल्टर आउट करने के लिए चीज इजी रहती
है इसके अंदर
इसीलिए डर टाइप जो है वो बताना कंपलसरी
होता है लेकिन उसका साइज बताना कंपलसरी
नहीं होता है वो बाय डिफॉल्टर में उनके
साइज जरूर होते हैं जो वो अपने आप से ले
लेते हैं ठीक है तो कुछ नहीं है
बस एक किसी भी डाटा का टाइप कर देते हैं
क्या होता है
तूने मेरी डाटा अपने मेली दो है नंबर और
टाइप
28 तक
पॉइंट के बाद क्या चीज क्या बना पॉइंट के
बाद कितना वालुज लगा सकते हो ठीक है नहीं
मां लो की आपने इस नंबर के अंदर यहां पर
लिख दिया
एग्जांपल
[संगीत]
है तो ऐसा राहत है यह पी का ठीक है अब मां
लो मैंने कोमा लगाकर इसके अंदर आगे
मैं इसको थोड़ा डाउट से बता देता हूं
इसका मतलब क्या हो जाएगी टोटल अपना नंबर
होने चाहिए पांच जिसमें से दो होंगे
ऐसा आएगा
छोटे में लिखो बड़े में लिखो बड़े छोटे
में लिखो छोटे बड़े में लिखो कोई फर्क
नहीं पड़ता है इसको उसको डालो उतना ही मटर
करता है
ओपन में लेना
नंबर का इस्तेमाल
पॉइंट वाले भी दाल रहे हैं फ्रूट्स का
मतलब फर्स्ट पॉइंट ही राहत है दोनों पकड़े
करते हैं जो नई करते हैं उनके लिए भी है
ये चीज नोट है अपना ही वही कम है
पॉइंट का ही कम करता है पॉइंट का वैल्यू
देता है इसकी रेंज इतनी ज्यादा होती है
क्योंकि ओनली पॉइंट वाला जिसके लिए कम कर
रहा है तो फिर बात है
अपन ये पी का वैल्यू
अलग-अलग
कुछ मेमोरी का खेल होता है
मेमोरी के हिसाब से चल रहा है
ठीक है
साथ में आपको मेमोरी का पूरा समझना है वो
चीज नहीं हो सकता है टेक्निकल
ठीक है तो यह निवेश हो जाएगा
जैसे मां लो की आपने पहले मंथ लिखा ठीक है
उसके बाद में आपको डेट लिखना पड़ता है
ठीक है
इंस्टॉल कर लिया था
की मतलब मैं उसे रिकॉर्डिंग
नए वाले तो
दाल रखा है
चाट के अंदर
कर सकते हो
भाई एसक्यूएल मैप एक अलग चीज है ठीक है ना
वह चीज आप समझ सकोगे
लेकिन डालते हुए पैरामीटर डालते हो लेकिन
पैरामीटर के हिसाब से वो अपना उसके अंदर
इंजेक्शन स्ट्राइक करते राहत है ठीक है ना
अब वो ट्राई क्या कर रहा है उसकी पीछे
क्या लॉजिक है वो क्या-क्या आपको दिखता
होगा बीच में की वो यूनिनॉर्टल्स का
इस्तेमाल कर रहा है ठीक है ना बिट्वॉयज के
इस्तेमाल कर रहा है वो सामने आपको दिखता
होगा लेकिन वो चीज़ एक्चुअली है क्या क्या
तो वो चीज अपन देखेंगे
अलग-अलग तरीके से कैसे कर सकता हूं
लेकिन मैं कस्टम क्वेरीज कैसे बनाऊं अपनी
की डेटाबेस मेरे से एक्सपोर्ट एक्सप्लॉयड
हो जाए
तो मैंने कल पासवर्ड बताया था इसका तो
प्लीज आप मुझे बताओ की इसका यूजरनेम क्या
है मतलब आप लोगों ने भी अगर यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड दाल रखा है तो चाट में लिख दो कोई
आपका खोल के नहीं देखने वाला है यहां पर
पीसी खोल के ओरेकल में हम डिटेल में क्या
स्टोर कर रखा है ठीक है तो अपने यूजरनेम
और पासवर्ड यहां पे लिख दो मैं अभी मेरे
को भी यहां पे समझना है की आप लोगों ने
कितने लोगों ने कनेक्ट करके देखा है
क्योंकि टेलीग्राम आपने किसी ने भी तास
बिल्कुल नहीं भेजो है मेरे को टैग तो नहीं
किया है मैंने चेक भी पड़े थे मेरे को
कहानी दिखा नहीं
गया था
बताओ
कैसे डालना होता है
है और कोई
चलो कोई नहीं
मैं आपको
सिस्टम पासवर्ड जो आपने स्क्रीनशॉट
लगाना है की कल मैंने कौन सा बताया था
ठीक है ताकि मुझे भी लगे ना की यार आप लोग
भी चलो वीडियो क्योंकि ग नहीं रहा चाट
चाहिए आपने कल के लेक्चर में इतना ध्यान
दिया था
ठीक है
दाल रहे हो इसके अंदर
ठीक है तो उसके लिए ना अपन क्या करेंगे
मां लो अपन से कुछ डालने में अगर ए जाता
है ठीक है ना इसके अंदर कोई डालने में अगर
ए जाता है तो अपन ऐसा नहीं कहना उसको एक
एक क्लिक में अपन वापस से पूरा लिख सकें
ठीक है ना तो उसके लिए अपन क्या करते हैं
ना एक छोटा सा हैक है
इसका मतलब जिंदगी होगी
तो मैं पहले कमांड यहां लिखूंगा ठीक है ना
यहां लिखने के बाद में कमांड यहां पे
पेस्ट करूंगा
जिससे अगर मेरे को यहां पर कोई एरर आता है
तो मैं डायरेक्टली मेरा नोटपैड करके किसी
को गिफ्ट कर दूंगा ताकि मुझे कोई यहां पर
झंझट नहीं करनी पड़ेगी वापस लिखने की यहां
पर कुछ करने की और मुझे दिक्कत नहीं
पड़ेगी
सबसे पहले मैं इस
कैसे बढ़ते हैं यार इसका
कंट्रोल
ठीक है फिर यह ब्रैकेट लगेंगे
अगर आप एक स्टूडेंट का डेटाबेस बना रहे हो
तो उसके अंदर क्या क्या डीटेल्स आप रख
सकते हो स्टूडेंट की
मैंने क्लास नंबर
रोल नंबर है
अगर
आप एक टेबल के अंदर रोल नंबर
का डाटा
अरे मैंने पीछे टैक्स के बड़े में बताया
तो उसके हिसाब से आपको क्या लगता है मतलब
एक वो है मतलब आम सेंस भी अगर आप लगाओगे
इसके अंदर की एक रोल नंबर का डाटा टाइप
क्या हो सकता है
बहुत अच्छे नंबर नाइस ओपन
को अगर कोई नया कलम चाहिए
अपना डिटेल की सेटिंग
डिटेल
अभिषेक भाई
इंटीरियर कितना आइडिया नहीं है मैंने उसे
भी नहीं किया
मुझे लगता है इसके अंदर
ठीक है तो अब मुझे अगला कलाम एड करने के
लिए कोमल लगाना देखा अगर मैं कोमल लगाना
भूल जाऊंगा ना तो मुझे
नाम यहां पर नाम दाल दिया मैंने नाम क्या
हो सकता है
स्टोर कर सकते हैं
तो वहां पर लिमिटेड
कर सकते हो कहानी और भी रन कर सकते हो ठीक
है
उनको पता है
ठीक है
अपन ठीक है ना बट अभी मैं सोच लेट हूं की
यार
तक जाता है ये ठीक है
ये मेरा दोस्त था पहले
एडमिशन अंडरस्कोर देखो एक चीज आप पैटर्न
स्क्रीन
ध्यान रखना
है
उसके अंदर रहती है
इसका इस्तेमाल नहीं कर सकते हो
यहां पर आता है
ठीक है
टाइम रहेगा मुझे ऐसा लगता है
तो अब एडमिशन डेट के अंदर है ना अब मैंने
आपको डेट का अलग से ही बता रखा है
लास्ट कॉलर
उसे करूंगा तो कम खत्म एक चीज याद रखना
कोई भी क्वेरी इसके अंदर रन करता नहीं है
पुरी है मैंने यहां पर इसको अलग-अलग लाइन
में लिखा है इसका मतलब ये बिल्कुल भी नहीं
है की आपको अलग-अलग लाइन में ही लिखना है
आप इसको से लाइन में भी रखोगे ना तो भी ये
अपना क्वेरी रन होगी
ठीक है जरूरी नहीं है की यह आपका अलग-अलग
ही उसमें रहे
बट अच्छा देखने के लिए मैंने उसको अलग अलग
कर है क्योंकि यार लुकिंग अच्छी लगती
चाहिए
ठीक है फिर यहां पर आएगा अपना कंडोम का
नाम डिटेल टाइप उसका साइज
नहीं है तो वह
साइज नहीं होता क्योंकि उसके अंदर
तो अब अपन इसको कॉपी करेंगे
पेस्ट करेंगे ठीक है
याद रखना यार ये चीज है ना मेरे भी
क्लासमेट्स वगैरा और मेरे भी जो भी है वह
सब लोग इस चीज को लेकर और रहते हैं की यार
टेबल बन गई क्यों नहीं मतलब टेबल से मैंने
क्रेडिट दाल दे लेकिन बनी क्यों नहीं भाई
आउटपुट नहीं देखते
टेबल बन गई है इसके अलावा कुछ भी आता है
ना और तुम मतलब आपके कहानी ना कहानी एरर
हुआ है
वो इतनी भी हार्ड नहीं होते समझना के लिए
अलग-अलग
फिर से अगर ये टेबल बनाने का ट्राई करूंगा
ठीक है ना तुम मुझे यहां पर आयरन दिखा
देगा की टेबल इस पीरियड यह स्टूडेंट के
आगे से है स्टार लगाया जहां भी आपका एरर
होगा ना उसकी आगे यह स्टार लगाएगी
ठीक है ना कभी ऊपर नीचे भी हो सकता है
लेकिन आसपास ही होगा हिस्टोरिक के आसपास
ही होगा चीज ठीक है तो ये स्टार समझना की
यार इधर ही महीने कहानी गलती कारी है या
फिर इस या फिर यहां पर कोई गलती हो रही है
मेरी पिछले लाइन की वजह से ठीक है ना बट
नीचे यहां पे देखो कितना क्लियर लिखा हुआ
है नाम इसे ऑलरेडी यूज्ड बाय एन
एक्जिस्टिंग ऑब्जेक्ट इसका सब कुछ
ऑब्जेक्टिव होता है टेबल एक टेबल राहत है
ठीक है ना
क्रिएट कमांड से आप टेबल बना सकते हो व्यू
बना सकते हो इंडेक्स भी बना सकते हो
प्रोसीजर्स भी बना सकते हो ठीक है और
रुक जो
तो मैं हर मैसेज यहां पर देखा हूं तो इस
टाइम करने का बिल्कुल भी नहीं है
वो सब बताया जाएगा उसका पेंशन मत करो ठीक
है
अभी इस टेबल के अंदर प्राइमरी की कोई सा
भी नहीं
तो देखो यहां पर
ऑब्जेक्ट के हिसाब से लेट है ठीक है तो
यहां पर लिखा हुआ है क्या
आम सेंस उसे करके समझ सकते मैंने पहले
कहानी उसे कर राखी है बना राखी है तो आप
नाम चेंज करके टेबल बना दो ठीक है अब मैं
नाम चेंज करके टेबल बनाता हूं लेकिन मैं
यहां आम लगाना भूल जाता हूं ठीक है तो
उसके बाद में का रहा रहेगा
देखो एडमिशन डेट के आगे यहां पर स्टार ए
गया है तो जैसे मैंने बताया की आपके लिए
स्टार आया उसके आगे पीछे देखो की आपकी कुछ
से लिखने या भूलने के चक्कर में आपके आगे
तो कहानी एरर ए रहा है की नहीं
ऐसा समझ रहा है की इसके आगे जो है
यह लाइन और करवा रहा है क्योंकि मैंने
बताया की अगर आपको बताना है इसको की आप एक
अगला कलम भी डालना चाहते हो
है ना अगर आपको कोई नया कलाम डालना चाहते
हो तो उसके लिए आपको कोमा लगाना पड़ेगा
अगर आप आम नहीं लगाते तो यह ऐसा संबंध
देगा ये शायद इतनी ही कलम से तो उसने वही
कहा की मेरे को पैरंटहस हैं मिसिंग दिखा
रहे हैं तो मतलब यह पेरेंट्स लगा के सेमी
कलर लगाना है ये ये इसको ऐसा ग रहा है की
शायद देना है ये लगाना मिसिंग कर दिया है
आपने लेकिन वो सीन नहीं है अपने पास और भी
कलम से अपन यहां पे आम लगाना है ठीक है ना
ये चीज आपको प्रैक्टिस के साथ-साथ समझ में
ए जाएगी की क्या है बट जॉइंट टेक्स्ट है
वो वैसा का वैसा ही रहेगा ठीक है तो अपनी
टेबल बन गई है और एक ऐसे ही कुछ कुछ एरर्स
हैं जो आपको कॉमनली देखने को मिलेंगे
स्टार्टिंग के वक्त में ठीक है जो मैंने
आपको अभी क्लियर कर दिया है की यह क्या
राहत है मतलब क्या चीज कैसे रहती है
टेबल कैसे बनाई जाति है
इसके अंदर
तो ऐसे टेबल बनाई जाति है अब मां लो एक
टेबल बन गई है
अब बने के बाद में मुझे चेक करने की यार
देखो
मुझे जन के लिए टेबल की क्या कलम है क्या
क्या है क्या इस टेबल का स्कीम क्या है तो
मुझे सीमा देखने के लिए एक कमांड होती है
तो आपको सेमी कॉलर लगाना
ठीक है
तो यहां पर से यह बताया की यार लाइन और हो
गई है तो मैं इसके अंदर आगे इसको कॉपी
करके यहां पेस करता हूं और यहां पर इंटर
दबाता हूं तो देखो ये मैंने स्टूडेंट का
टेबल बनाया था देखिए अब देखो मैंने ना नाम
के अंदर जितना मैंने डाटा जितना मैंने
इसको दे रखा था क्या कहते हैं अपना
और स्कैनर कितना मैंने इसको साइज दे रखा
था तो उतना यहां पर ए जाते हैं ठीक है ना
ठीक है तो भाई ये ऐसा मत समझना की इस नाम
के चक्कर में यहां पे इतना है ठीक है ना
ये हाईएस्ट के हिसाब से आता है यहां पर
ठीक है
तो भी चलेगा यहां तक दिमाग मत लगाना मैंने
बस आपको ऐसे ही बता दिया है
तो मैंने मेरे को सच में किसी ने बताया
नहीं बताया
इसका डिस्क्रिप्शन चेक किया मैंने
मतलब है डिस्क्रिप्शन मेरी जैसे लोगों को
स्पेलिंग नहीं आई डिस्क्रिप्शन
तो देखो यहां पर यह नल क्वेश्चन मार्क
करके लिखा हुआ ए रही है कांस्टेंट वगैरा
जो रूल राहत है यह टेबल तो अभी यह रूल ये
इसको अपन ढूंढ देता है एंट्री करने का वो
है क्या डाटा इंटर करना चाहिए ठीक है ना
आगे अपने रूल्स भी लगाएंगे टेबल के अंदर
की ये ये रूल्स रहेंगे ठीक है ना डाटा
इंटर करते वक्त
ठीक है ताकि आ डाटा की जो एंट्री है वह
सैनिटाइजर होती है
इंटीग्रिटी उसकी मेंटेन है उसको कांस्टेंट
अच्छी बात है
चलो ठीक है अच्छी बात है
ठीक है तो बट फिर भी ऐसा अपन फरवरी में कम
बिल्कुल नहीं करने वाले हैं आराम से हर एक
एक पार्ट को अपने कर्म आराम से देंगे
ठीक है
एकदम ठीक है टेबल देखना बनाना अब अपन
देखेंगे टेबल्स के रूल्स क्या-क्या हो
सकते हैं डाटा एंट्री करते हैं ठीक है ना
तो अपन अभी चलते हैं मेरी पीपीटी की तरफ
में जो मैं नहीं
कोई डाटा एंट्री करते वक्त में उसका
वैलिडेशन करने को अपनी इंटीग्रिटी कहते
हैं
उसका वैलिडेशन चेक करना
है यह
वैलिड है की नहीं है
की नहीं है ना तो इंटीग्सिटी में राहत है
तो फिलहाल अपना मौसी कम करेंगे
बहुत महत्वपूर्ण रोल निभाती है
ना
यह ना प्राइमरी की जो इसके अंदर डालते हैं
अब देखो
अपन लोगों
ने ऐसा नंबर दिया जाता था यार रोल नंबर
दिया जाता था
स्कूल टाइम में फोन नंबर भी से इसके फोन
नंबर
मिलता है कंपलसरी
ठीक है ना तो उससे क्या राहत है ना अपन को
डाटा फाइंडिंग में करो के अंदर रहना बहुत
आसानी रहती है की यार है ना की वो डाटा वो
वाला पार्ट खाली नहीं है ठीक है ना डाटा
भर सकते हैं तो यार अपने अपने हाथ में
रहते हैं की अपन डाटा भरे तो कोई खाली भर
देता है तो इस चिकन के अंदर प्राइमरी की
आवाज राहत है ना ये मोस्टली अपन खुद से ही
जेनरेट करके देते हैं सामने वाले को जैसे
हर यूजर का एक आईडी होता है हर स्टूडेंट
का एक आईडी होता है
वैसा ही प्राइमरी की क्या कम होता है यह
एकदम
खाली नहीं होता है मतलब ऐसा नहीं की किसी
को आइडिया नहीं मिला है या किसी को अपना
वही कम राहत है ठीक है
अभी तो नहीं जो राहत है
तो अपन नाम
सबका अपना अपना नाम होता है यार सबको नाम
डालने का ऐसे ही है की यार आपका नाम क्या
है आपका नाम क्या है ठीक है ना ऐसे तो कोई
न्यूज़ का नाम ना हो
ठीक है ना तो उसे नाम में कहना सबके नाम
से तो हो सकते हैं लेकिन नाम ऐसे नहीं
किसी का नाम ही नहीं है तो उसे कैसे में
नॉर्मल कैटिगरी में उसको दाल देते की यार
तुम ज्यादा तुम एक कम करो की अपना
खाली
रखना हूं ठीक है
यूनिक होना चाहिए इसका सबसे अच्छा
एग्जांपल अपन देखें तो फोन नंबर
डालने का जो ऑप्शन राहत है
वह ऑप्शनल राहत
भी चलेगा लेकिन आप जब फोन नंबर दाल रहे हो
तो फोन नंबर किसी दूसरे से मेल नहीं खाना
चाहिए आपको यूनिक होना चाहिए वो फोन नंबर
ठीक है तो उसे कैसे में अपन यूनिक की
कांस्टेंट का इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं
ठीक है अब उसके बाद में अपना आता है
डिफॉल्ट
ले लेट है
ठीक है
मां लो अपने और डाटा की तरह कुछ डाटा डाला
नहीं है तो बाय सेट कर रखा रहेगा वो वहां
पर ए जाएगा
तो ले लगा वहां पर अगर कोई ज्यादा रहेगा
तो अपना
डाला है कुछ नहीं डाला होगा तो वो डिफॉल्ट
में डाला रहेगा वो ए जाएगा
प्राइमरी के राहत है वो अपना इन दोनों का
मिक्सर राहत है नोटों का और यूनिक की का
ठीक है
ठीक है अब आते हैं
विद एग्जांपल
को मिलने हैं तो अपना वो आईडीबीएस में
आरडीबीएमएस की कैटिगरी इसके अंदर कैटिगरी
के अंदर आता है तो फॉरेन की जो है वो कम
आई है डाटा को मिलने के अंदर जैसे की मां
लो की ना आपका एक स्टूडेंट का पेपर है
ठीक है
अब मां लो यह ना उसका एक और अगर अपने
स्क्रीन में दाल दिया की जैसे
बीकॉम करके अपना दाल दिया यहां पर ठीक है
ना और मैंने उसका आईडी भी रखा bhi.com
करके रख दिया मैंने ठीक है ना अब मैंने
यहां पे बीसीए की करके दाल दिया और यहां
पे इसका आईडी भी मैंने इसी कर दिया ठीक है
तो देखो इस कैसे में क्या है ना और यहां
पर मां लो की मैंने स्टूडेंट के टेबल पे
रखा है देखो
बिल्कुल आपको समझ में नहीं ए रही देखिए
अगर आप बाद में स्टेबल को समझना की कोशिश
कर दो स्क्रीनशॉट
करता है उसको कैसे मेरी सेटिंग समझ में ए
रही है लेकिन हां वो बांदा फिर भी मुझे
पास कर रहा है उसके लिए बंदे को
बांदा क्योंकि शायद वो केमिस्ट के पास बैठ
के देखा रहेगा
ठीक है
सामने बस दिखाने के लिए वो लिखा हुआ है
तो मां लो अगर आप पर आपने एक स्टूडेंट का
टेबल बना रखा है इन्होंने नाम दाल रखा है
उसका आईडी दाल रखा है फिर आप उसके लिए
यहां पे कोर्स डालते हो उसका तो आपने क्या
कर रखा है ना इस भारत के अंदर अपना आईडी
का ऑप्शन दिया था की फोर्स
आईडी डालो यहां पर ठीक है ना अब अपने क्या
हुआ है ना पुराने भी टेबल के अंदर ये जो
आईडी वाला था इस आईडी वाले इस कलम को अपने
प्राइमरी की दे रखा था ठीक है अब प्राइमरी
किसी क्या होगा ना इस आईडी के अंदर ना ही
कोई रिपीटेशन होगा और ना ये खाली रहना
ठीक है तो इसके चक्कर में प्राइमरी की
जरूर बनाएंगे
यह जो स्टूडेंट वाला रहेगा वह किसी और चीज
से लिंक रहेगा लाइब्रेरी के लिंक रहेगा एक
की भाई चेक करने के लिए उसे करता है की
नहीं तो ऐसी भी चीज रहती है तो भैया इसको
एक जो टेबल है वो अलग-अलग टेबल से लिंक हो
सकता है ठीक है उसको लिंक करने के लिए
अपने फॉरेन की कम आई है
अपन दूसरी टेबल का नाम दाल देते हैं और
कौन से कलम से अपन उसको लिंक कर रहे हैं
उसे कलम का नाम दाल देते हैं मोस्टली आपको
अगर आप किसी कलम से लिंक कर रहे हो उसे
कैसे में आपको बस एक प्राइमरी की वाले कलम
से ही उसको लिंक करना है ठीक है क्योंकि
ताकि अपना रिपीटेशन है
अपना वह खाली ना हो
इसके लिए प्राइमरी की वह होना जरूरी है
जिससे आप लिंक कर रहे हो ठीक है
स्टूडेंट के अंदर अपने यहां पर क्वेश्चन
दाल दिया फॉरेन की जो लिंक कर रहा है अपने
स्पिरिट टेबल से कैसे लिंकिंग होती है यह
अपन आगे जाकर देखेंगे लेकिन अभी अपन एक
फॉरेन टी के बड़े में पढ़ रहे हैं तो उसको
मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन कर रहा हूं इसमें
ज्यादा दिमाग अभी मत लगाना जब आप इसको बाद
में आगे जाकर फैक्ट्री देखोगे तो आप
ज्यादा इस चीज को समझ पाओगे ठीक है ना
जितना अभी समझ रहे हो अच्छी बात है अगर आप
समझ रहे हो तो नहीं समझ रहे हो तो कोई
टेंशन लेने की बात नहीं है जब इसको अगर
प्रैक्टिकल भी आगे जाके करेंगे तो आपको और
अच्छे से चीज समझ में आएगी मगज में क्लियर
होगा
दाल रखा है जो इस टेबल के प्राइमरी के
वाले कलम से लिंक हो रखा है ठीक है
तो पहले स्टेप में जाके चेक कर देंगे की
भाई वो डाटा यहां पर अवेलेबल है की नहीं
उसे कलम का तो ही वह जाकर एंट्री लगा नहीं
तो एंट्री नहीं लगा
ठीक है
एग्जांपल के साथ में समझा दिया है ठीक है
समझ में ए गया है वो प्लीज मुझे चाट में
बता दो कितने लोग का समझ में ए गया है
ताकि थोड़ा अच्छा है
प्लीज मुझे बता दो एक बार की आप लोग को
समझ में ए रहा है की नहीं
कोई बात नहीं
देखेंगे
तो आज आज के लिए इतना ही ठीक है
थोड़ा सा
तो आज के लिए
पता करना है ठीक है इनको आपको
समझना है
और इंप्लीमेंटेशन इसका कल हो ही जाएगा बट
इसको रिवाइज करके आपको आना है ताकि कल के
इंप्लीमेंटेशन के अंदर
आपको दिक्कत ना आए
ठीक है तो आपको जवाब चाहिए समझ रहे हो अगर
आपने खुद से ट्राई भी किया है करने का तो
आपको वो चीज आपको जो लोग पहले से इतने
सारे वो समझ गए होंगे मैं क्या करने वाला
हूं बट फिर भी मैं बता रहा हूं फिर से
आपको हिंदी में जाना है
तो आज कल में ए जाएगा
है उसके बड़े में आपको कमेंट में लिख देने
का है की आपने यह पढ़ा है यह आपके पास हो
गया है
ठीक है
तो प्लीज मुझे चाट में बता दो
भाई दोबारा
से समझ में ए जाएगा ठीक है कल भी ओवरव्यू
इसका मिल जाएगा आपको उसका दिक्कत मत करना
ये स्लाइड जो लास्ट वाली थी ये कल की कल
के उसमें पीपीटी में पहले मैं रख दूंगा
मैं
ठीक है सो थैंक यू गैस आपको अगर कुछ
कंप्लेन है या फिर कुछ कैसा लगा आपको सेशन
कोई फीडबैक अगर आप देना चाहे तो आई एम ओपन
पर फीडबैक
मतलब
नोट्स भाई तब तक नहीं मिलेंगे जब तक आप
लोगों आप लोग मुझे तक वगैरा करके नहीं
बताते हो मुझे लेकिन यह पोस्ट में नहीं
दिखता है आप लोग का टास्क या सिर्फ
टेलीग्राम के अंदर समा करके नहीं दाल देते
टास्क की ये कर लिया है वो कर लिया है
मुझे टैग करके तब तक मैं नहीं समझ पाऊंगा
की आप लोग आप लोग सीरियस हो और आपको नोट्स
देनी चाहिए क्योंकि सब कुछ लाइव चल रहा है
रिकॉर्ड है आप चाहे तो खुद के भी नोट्स
बना सकते हो ठीक है
बट आपकी अगर मेहनत लिखिए तो नोट देने में
भी अच्छा लगे बस बात इतनी सी है
मतलब जब तक लेकिन पर पोस्ट नहीं आई है तब
तक टेलीग्राम पर मुझे टैग करके आप
स्क्रीनशॉट
हम लोग यहां पर दाल रहे हैं
सो आज के लिए उतना ही गैस थैंक यू बाय बाय
गुड नाइट शब्बा खैर जय हिंद वंदे मातरम जय
हो